Hallo Deutschschule.
Training Buchstabieren.
Deutschland.
In Deutschland leben 83 Millionen Menschen.
Die Hauptstadt von Deutschland ist Berlin.
Wo wohnst du?
Vogel
Der Vogel fliegt durch die Luft.
Viele Vögel fliegen im Winter nach Süden.
Mülleimer
In jedem Park gibt es mindestens einen Mülleimer.
Ich bringe meinen Müll zur Mülltonne.
Armbanduhr
Meine Armbanduhr ist eine Smartwatch.
Mit meiner Armbanduhr kann ich sogar meinen Puls
messen.
Trägst du eigentlich eine Armbanduhr?
Rucksack
Der rote Rucksack.
Jonathan geht mit seinemneuen Rucksack in die Schule.
Flugzeug
Das Flugzeug fliegt in einer
Höhe von 10.000 Metern.
Das Flugzeug fliegt mit einer
Geschwindigkeit von 900 Km/h.
Mikrowelle
Das Essen in der Mikrowelle aufwärmen.
Heute mache ich mir einen leckeren Hotdog in der
Mikrowelle.
Was ist dein Lieblingsessen?
Blumenstrauß
Ein Blumenstrauß mit 8 roten Rosen.
Als Zeichen meiner Liebe schenke
ich dir heute diesen Blumenstrauß.
Kinderwagen
Das Baby liegt im Kinderwagen.
Die Mutter schiebt den
Kinderwagen durch die Stadt.
Kaffeemaschine.
Die Kaffeemaschine kocht Kaffee.
In der Frühstückspause trinke ichheute eine heiße Tasse Kaffee.
Trinkst du Kaffee oder Tee?
Staubsauger
Der Staubsauger saugt Staub.
Heute sauge ich meine Wohnung mit dem Staubsauger.
Werde Mitglied der Hallo Deutschschule
und unterstütze uns mit einem kleinen Betrag.
So hast du viele Vorteile und wir können weiterhin unser Bestes für dich geben!
Klicke auf den "Mitglied werden" -Button
Flaschenöffner
Die Flasche öffnen mit dem Flaschenöffner.
Wo ist bloß mein Flaschenöffner geblieben?
Ah, er lag auf dem Sofa!
Ventilator
Der Ventilator macht kühle Luft in einem Raum.
Ich liebe den Ventilator in meinem Büro.
Geburtstagstorte
Auf der Geburtstagstorte ist eine Kerze.
Sandra hat von ihren Kollegeneine Geburtstagstorte bekommen.
Wann hast du Geburtstag?
Das Toastbrot mit dem Toaster toasten.
Zum Frühstück esse ich ein leckeres Toastbrot.
Waschbecken
In jedem Badezimmer gibt es auch ein Waschbecken.
Ich wasche mir die Hände im Waschbecken.
Dusche
Nach dem Duschen föhne ich mir die Haare.
Die Deutschen duschen im Durchschnitt 6 Minuten.
Badewanne
In eine Badewanne passen 150 Liter Wasser.
Heute nehme ich ein Bad in meiner Badewanne.
Hast du auch eine Badewanne?
Hast du gewusst?
Du kannst auch Mitglied der Hallo Deutschschule werden!
Es gibt viele Vorteile
Auf unserer Kanalseite kannst du dich einschreiben!
Werde ONLINE-SCHÜLER der Hallo Deutschschule!
Abonniere jetzt den Kanal der HalloDeutschschule
und aktiviere das kleine Glöckchen!
Gib uns jetzt einen Daumen nach oben
und klicke auf diese Playlist für weitere
Videos zum Deutsch lernen.